he's very pro-asian he believes no i
like dude bobby's one of the funniest
human beings on the [ __ ] planet and i
was talking about that with reuben paul
yesterday at the laugh fact i said that
is one of the funniest [ __ ]
period straight up straight down that's
how racist this goddamn business is
bobby should be the most famous
[ __ ] on the planet that's happy
no i'm serious yeah yeah but you always
complain that you didn't have more than
25 minutes you always said recovery i
don't have i can't do
more that
it's like this i say but bobby you could
do no that's all i have
that's all is that really how i sound
yes
bobby you're still honestly honestly
yeah remember when i met you is this why
i mentioned hawaiians i don't know i
tried to learn how to surf and you were
red remember you were burned oh yeah
yeah and you were like this ah
i'm hurting i'm hurting no no no
remember your hope i thought you were
exaggerating me no you your hair
yo this is the way i talk no no
you're here
that's how i talk bro
yo nah no oh [ __ ]
more like this yeah yeah doesn't mean
yeah oh [ __ ] even even even when during
the joe rogan thing when that whole the
carlos mencia thing oh my god and they
go way back i started laughing because
bobby goes yeah he's still no no no i'm
sorry don't don't talk to me
[Laughter]
bobby bailed [ __ ] bobby bailed it was i
said that's bobby though bobby weasel
because at first you were like you're
like this yeah yeah yeah man he's still
no no no no no no no i don't forget it
forget what i said i said
that's bobby
but that's what makes me i've known you
that long you were like this all i have
is 25 minutes and then i pull my pants
down i go away
that's all i have is my pubic hair thing
i go
have you done a special yeah never done
it how to [ __ ] crazy never done one how
the [ __ ] do you not do a special broke
god really listen to me right now okay
focus around me right now you need
people to write for you no no no i got
just listen to what i'm saying godfrey
okay
no special
i got nothing right
but look at the house that i have it's
[ __ ] dope so my point is is this
right what's up i'm doing fine
no
this is what i'm saying right
the road the road that i'm traveling
right is
with a lot of fruit
there's fruits on the trees and there's
a lot of wealth and there's a lot of uh
you're doing family and love and
you're staying away from the [ __ ] [ __ ]
huh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] just i mean you
said you're doing fine you seem like
what you're saying is you're avoiding
the [ __ ] you don't want to go
through maybe you're not going to you
don't want to go i don't know it just
sounds like
you know our business is is a mind [ __ ]
so
when you find like your path it's
awesome you don't have to find other
when you can do well without [ __ ] ice
you can find your own way that's awesome
i found i've i've always found my way
and i'm going to be calm now all right i
want to be you know you don't want to be
competitive i know i know i don't want
to be people no no no
in fact this is the way i'm going to
talk for the rest of the podcast i know
i i think you're lying no yeah
so my my little my my dear black friend
yes
may i say something to you yes you may
the road that i'm traveling it's full of
fruit
right
and i bear the fruit it's full of um
you know what i mean earthly energies
yeah and yeah and it's it's i succumb to
the wealth of my region
okay
and
just listen to whatever everything's
wordless yeah yeah what right and i feel
beloved and i feel like i'm the right
path to the glory
i'm on the right
when i get emotional i stutter oh okay
yeah right so if i was doing a ted talk
or whatever right it would right right
right past the global glory i would say
like that okay so my point is is this i
dated a guy with a stutter did you
really yeah he couldn't say i have like
a couple l's in my name and he had a
hard time with l well a lot of is he was
he white no he's mexican that's good
there's something some i have a couple
of white friends that don't say they're
l's like i made fun of mark maron
because he don't really say his elves
that well
what does he like i really like it
no really yeah tom brokaw newscaster
yeah
doesn't say his elves like uh or
my other friend too he's black dude he
doesn't say his l's and he doesn't
really say his l it's like a weird as a
little impediment